welcome back to new rockstars I'm marina
masterís you guys bombarded our social
media with requests for breakdowns of
this Star Trek Picard pilot episode and
I bombarded Eric's face with spitballs
until he let me do it so here I am
tackling episode 1 that's how you know
new rockstars loves you because really
only 12 people have actually subscribed
to CBS all access
just kidding it's more like 15 as always
here's a giant spoiler warning if you
haven't seen the episode okay so the
episode starts with a Picard dream
sequence which is also the way first
contact begins in his dream the song
blue sky plays which makes sense because
this is a dream about data and data
saying that song at Riker and Troy's
wedding in Star Trek nemesis Picard
plays poker with data as I scream and
hyperventilate there in the bar on
Picard's original enterprise but data's
uniform isn't the one that they wore on
that ship because dreams are just weird
like that
Picard drinks tea as I weep hot tears
and he notices that they're close to
Mars there's an explosion which
references events that happen in
children of Mars which is a short you
can also see on CBS all access
okay so Picard wakes up on earth back on
his family vineyards he has a good boy
pupper that he's number one which is of
course what he used to call raker I get
so another one we cut to a Boston
skyline where there's actually a Ferengi
Alliance symbol on a building which
means that quark will haunt my dreams
tonight we then are introduced to dodge
who has as a hand boyfriend which is a
species that was actually introduced in
season 2 of Star Trek discovery dodge
tells him that she got a fellowship at
the daystrom Institute which has been
mentioned a few times in different Star
Trek series for various sciency reasons
richard de strim is a scientist from the
original Star Trek series who creates an
AI that pulls a Skynet but no one really
holds it against him because he still
gets an institute named after him moving
on
okay so dodge pulls a Jason Bourne and
gets her Android kick ass mode activated
when Romulan soldiers knife her
boyfriend in the chest and tried to take
her hostage she does bleed human blood
and clearly doesn't know that she's an
Android because she's all like I'm from
Seattle bruh from Seattle
okay so now we get our series intro
which doesn't have narration but it does
have a lot of references in metaphors so
I guess that's fine too there is a shard
of glass that falls through Picard's
vineyard abhorred cube DNA strands the
iris of an eye Romulus being destroyed
and then facta Picard who is my dad on
Picard's chateau he drinks decaf Earl
Grey tea now because he's older but
still into self-care Picard gets
interviewed and goes over the events of
the supernova that destroyed Romulus and
the failed attempt to save the lives
under attack by the synthetics as a
result of the attack Starfleet
subsequently banned synthetics and we
learned that Picard quit Starfleet
because he was not prepared to stand by
and be a spectator by the way I think
this is a great way to recap the events
as they stand we get a master class in
acting from Patrick Stewart and it's a
great reminder of who Picard is as a
person not to mention that I personally
think his emphasis on refusing to
distinguish between lives and Romulan
lives is a message that we could all use
a reminder of today
Picard quote Shakespeare to his dog Oh
which is a reminder that he's an avid
Shakespeare fan and dodge finds Picard
core then has another data dream where
data is painting something that he did
very often on next generation they're
both wearing their next-gen uniforms so
of course by now I'm screaming again no
big deal no big deal moving on okay
we're moving on great mm-hmm okay
Picard goes to Starfleet quantum
archives and it's Easter Egg time baby
but before I list all those juicy juicy
eggs here's a quick thanks to our
sponsor this video is brought to you by
the red orig makes everyday goods to a
standard that you don't see every day
they streamline your life by turning the
things you carry like backpacks chargers
and wallets into tools for better living
their flagship product the ridge wallet
was launched on Kickstarter in 2013 and
now sits the front pockets of over half
a million men and women you don't want
one of those overstuffed wallets with
old receipts pouring out at the top
making you look like a mess I have a
bunch of purses and some of them are
really small like if you have a clutch
then you can't always fit your wallet
inside so this is great because it
actually fits right in and if you have a
dress with pockets this is the dream
this is their aluminum wallet and the
raw color they also have other colors
including some very flashy tiki designs
flight it's strong and
a cool industrial chic vibe the ridge is
a minimal front pocket wallet that's
designed to streamline what you carry
every day
it has 30,000 five-star reviews and is a
better way to carry your cash in cards
there's a lifetime warranty if loved it
and free returns if you don't it comes
in titanium carbon fiber aluminum and
over a dozen different styles and colors
they also have great backpacks and
travel bags with RFID blocking pockets
and optional device charging batteries
get 10% off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to rich
comm slash new rock stars
that's Ridge comm slash new rock stars
and use code new rock stars find the
link in the video's description okay
guys time to crack those eggs
Picard's archive room has a model of the
USS stargazer a Klingon bat'leth his
book of the complete works of
Shakespeare a model of the enterprise-e
a model of the captain's yacht shuttle
and the Picard a banner from TNG season
7 high role model Picard finds one of
two paintings that data made and he
figures out that Dodge is data's
daughter because although data is a very
perfect Android he's not super creative
and he just names his painting daughter
- Brian's Picard and she gets attacked
again and this time killed by Romulans
one of whom bites a capsule of acid and
spits it on her which like wow don't
accidentally mistake your gum for that
capsule because damn look on picard goes
to dr. jarate played by Alison Pill and
she shows him up but up up before she
explains the data downloading himself
into p4 it didn't really work and that
no Android has ever been like data again
which you're goddamn right they haven't
and it saves us from having to rewatch
nemesis honest she also talks about
Bruce Maddox who was a scientist from
TNG season 2 episode 9 who wanted to
take data apart to create a super army
here we find out that dodge was created
with a twin sister so G within me it's
og who is a doctor and also already
knows she has a twin sister so they're
different somehow
it's revealed that she's working with
the surviving Romulans who are living in
a reclaimed Borg cube
ah as I can't deal with this by myself
this is too much information it's too
crazy it's too much in my childhood
Filip help me help me out here no okay
just me then guys before I pass out we
have a patron only discord server where
you can actually talk to us and ask me
and Eric and Tommy and Philip
all the questions about all the videos
or whatever else you want to know I can
tell you the story of how I actually in
real life met brent Spiner and he's
super nice and reminder that new rock
stars offers bonus monthly videos
exclusive to patrons for the kind of
content YouTube won't let us release
publicly on this channel for example
Eric did a frame-by-frame analysis of
the church scene in Kingsman and a
breakdown of the shining you can access
all of it by supporting us on patreon
and a huge thank you to all current
patrons hit like and subscribe follow me
on Twitter at Marina Mastro's follow new
rock stars on socials at new rock stars
I have to go sleep for a thousand years
ie
[Music]